I make money trading for just 60 minutes
and I look for only one specific pattern
that shows up right at Market open every
day and my students consistently make
money doing this every day as well after
5 years of going in circles wasting a
bunch of time trying a bunch of
complicated strategies I finally figured
out a simple repeatable setup that
actually works and it takes less than 1
hour a day to consistently execute no
more over complicated trading tons of
indicators and sitting at your charts
for hours on end after failing for so
long I finally realized the key to
becoming successful at trading for me
was to focus on just key areas of
support and resistance it completely
simplified my trading instead of chasing
the market and forcing trades I started
to wait for the market to come to me
that shift not only made me more relaxed
but it also gave me stronger risk reward
ratios me to risk a small amount for a
large amount to give you a super quick
overview before we dive into the nuts
and bols of how you can consistently
execute this pattern yourself every day
all I do is when the US Market opens I
look at the first 30 to 60 Minutes all
I'm looking for is a clean support and
resistance level and then I look for a
few key patterns for example right here
there's a nice double top all I do then
is I see a nice Candlestick pattern and
then I enter in on a trade short betting
that the market is going to go down and
then from there I let the market L out
I've noticed over time that the market
consistantly has a reversal in the first
30 to 60 Minutes of a trading day and so
what this strategy does is it allows you
to take advantage of that reversal and
then coupling that with looking for key
areas of resistance or support you're
able to essentially ping pong the market
between those levels capturing a big
potential profit for a smaller amount of
risk and this is all I do every day this
is the only thing I look for every
single day and it allows my trading to
be super simple and straightforward so
that you can go into every day with a
plan and know how to execute it instead
of what I did before when I was
unprofitable I was trying to match what
the market was doing and that just was
not profitable and I know from teaching
a ton of people how to do this that's
the exact same way they feel as well and
to help you consistently execute this
strategy I've created a free 14-page
guide that will walk you through the
major patterns that I use to look for
reversals look to enter in on my trades
for confirmation every time I look for
this strategy you can download it in the
link in the description of this video or
using this QR code now to break this
down for you in a simple entry checklist
the first thing I do coming into trading
every single morning is look at the big
picture now I trade on a one minute
chart of the NASDAQ futures but you can
really trade this on any time frame or
any Market I have a lot of students that
just trade this on an hour chart they
use it on crypto they use it on Forex
you're just reading the candlesticks at
the end of the day there's no indicators
anything fancy so that's the big
important thing is that you can trade
this anywhere but this is what I trade
on and so the first thing I do when I
come into the market here I kind of just
zoom out and look at okay you know the
Market's opening up here in a minute
what am I looking for right where are
the key areas of support and resistance
now there is a big one down here and
then there's kind of a big one up here
for a resistance level you know it it
touched here yesterday it touched here
today uh and then there was a big bottom
down here and another thing to keep in
mind is there was a touch here overnight
and then this is where the market closed
the previous day and so sometimes the
market will bottom at the previous day's
close so I just drew this one as well to
just keep in mind for that and so when
the market opened here it opens up at
7:30 my time but this is just the New
York Stock Exchange open so 9:30 Eastern
technically so all I looked for is okay
well we opened and we bottomed here at
that you know overnight previous Market
close level and so in trading you always
want to just keep an open mind of okay I
don't know where the Market's going to
bounce but I'm going to be ready for if
it's going to bounce at an area I like
and so what I was looking for here was
it to potentially bounce here because it
bounced here once and then it showed
some strength and came back and started
to make a double bottom that's a really
good key pattern and so from there I
pulled up a risk reward tool and I said
okay if I jump in here and I put my stop
here and I'm risking let's say $90 I'm
trading on a small account right now
trying to grow it again just to prove
that this works on a small account again
you've seen just like that example I
just had before I've used this on a
large account you can use this kind of
on any side that you want but
essentially what this tool is showing
you is that okay if I trade four
contracts I risk $90 where can I you
know if I Target I like to Target three
times my risk if it goes up here I'll
make around
$270 so to go into the live recording of
this because this is an actual trade I
took recently is once it kind of had
that double bottom I looked for a buy
and so to kind of that's kind of jumping
forwards a little bit but to go back to
really step two of my process is look at
this downtrend line right here that's a
big key to these reversals is seeing
that okay well the current downtrend is
broken because if you're looking for a
reversal trade Will the Market into a
support or resistance level and I don't
have it drawn here on this chart but we
just looked at the the level that we're
bouncing off of the support level would
have been right here and the key is well
the market in a in a strong downtrend it
could just keep going and break through
a support level and so what you want to
do is you want to first make sure that
that downtrend is actually broken so
that it can start a new uptrend and so
that's what I look for every time as
well is make sure analyze look at the
candlesticks just look at the swings you
don't need to use any indicators or
anything you're just looking at the raw
data I also realize over time that
simplified things way more for me is
just looking at the raw data of the
trade and so from there okay step two
downtrend is broken clearly when this
happens and then after that it comes
down here and makes a nice clean double
bottom and then I you know I wasn't
quite sure about it after this
Candlestick because this was a really
strong bearish Candlestick I wanted to
see a little more strength sometimes in
the market what will happen after a big
Candlestick like this it'll it'll bounce
back a little bit just because it's
overextended a little bit but then it'll
continue lower and so what I was I
waited for is I waited for that bounce
see if it continued lower with this
Candlestick right here essentially
that's it Contin lower and that failed
and so then I put in an order right
there jumped in long and then I let the
market play out I moved my stop to break
even after it broke this previous High
cuz I you know I wanted to take that
risk off the table you don't want to let
the market go in your favor and then
come back and knock you out at a loss
and then from there I just trailed up my
stop loss I put in a limit order
actually at two times my risk just
because the market kind of felt a little
choppy I was totally happy getting two
times my risk for a profit and you know
it you can clearly see there it almost
hit me and so then I just elected to
kind of move things up a little bit cuz
there was this uptrend here I kind of
like to manage with that as well and
then from there it just looked like it
was starting to slow down I could I kind
of was just reading into the
candlesticks reading into the market
that you know it's either going to
continue higher or if it kind of you
know starts to just slow down I'm going
to move my stop loss up and get out you
know it's at that two times my
profit that I already am kind of looking
for you know I only risk like $90 on
this trade so I'm up really two and a
half times right now and so at that
point you know I'm I'm happy with the
trade that's $250 you know quickly after
you know 20 minutes and then at that I
called it for the day I didn't even have
to trade for 60 minutes and you can see
my read There was right and the market
kind of started to pull back and at that
point that was just a quick scalp and so
this is just what I repeat consistently
every single day and so make sure to
download that 14 page free Candlestick
patterns guide in the link in the
description of this video or with this
QR code right here it'll really help you
consistently execute this strategy and
show you more patterns that I use to
enter in on other than the quick ones I
just went through as well if you want a
more in-depth guide into this strategy
and more trade examples to kind of flush
out how it actually works check out this
video right here